-Hey, everybody, welcome back.
We are joined now
by one of our friends.
You know him as the host of "All
In with Chris Hayes" on MSNBC.
Chris Hayes is joining us,
everybody.
-How you doing, Seth?
-I'm doing very well.
Right before we went live
with this interview,
I was talking
with you and your wife.
I know that you -- Three kids,
two whose school year is over,
and you're basically
home-schooling.
How's that going?
-It's --
Well, I should stipulate
that Kate, my wife, has been
doing the lion's share of it
But I do have --
She basically has
2 1/2 hours of the day
to herself.
She's working all day
home-schooling,
and then she's anchor-producin
me when I do the show.
So she has very long days.
So there's 2 1/2 hours
that I have the kids.
And, you know, it's --
I mean, if I have one more
Zoom meeting number or passwor
or app that needs some login
I'm going to lose my mind.
And everyone's doing their best,
and everyone's trying,
but, like, it's hard.
And, you know,
it's a lot of work.
And it's hard
to not be distracted,
particularly when you've got
the show that night.
-Yep.
-And there's a lot
of kind of like, "Alright,
why don't you just go read
over here?"
-Yeah.
Well, I think we have
something in common,
which is when we realized we had
to do our shows from home,
that we did not have
very good Internet.
Is that true?
-Correct, yes.
I had to upgrade to
the premium level of Internet.
It's a funny thing I've noticed.
So, we're getting
this weird window
into people's Internet quality
through the various Zoom,
and there's no predicting.
Like some people,
like Nancy Pelosi,
the Speaker of the House,
who she and her husband have a
fair amount of personal wealth
That's a publicly known thing.
-Yep.
-Not very good Internet.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-And then -- I mean,
it's, like, it's crazy
how bad American broadband
seems to be generally
as we're learning
throughout this thing,
or just how inconsistent it is
across various domains.
-Yes. And when you think
about Nancy Pelosi, also,
you know, the Bay Area is so -
-San Francisco, right.
-Your mom like mine
was the teacher.
Your father worked
at Department of Health.
They seem like very helpfu
parents to have
during a time like this.
-They are. I mean, we miss the
because, like everyone,
you know, like everyone,
they're sheltering in place in
the home I grew up in the Bronx.
So we're doing a lot
of FaceTiming with --
you know, with Nana and Papa
And, you know, FaceTiming
with people,
particularly loved ones,
is always a little weird.
But they're great. My mom ha
been offering teaching advic
and sort of goals for lessons.
My father, I think
was part of the reason
that I kind of locked into thi
story early was just seeing --
He worked in New York City
Department of Public Health,
which is an incredible
institution,
has been for literally
over a century,
just, you know, an amazing place
and handled the Ebola crisis
very well.
So I think I had sort of
learned from him
about a certain kind of
cast of mind
that public health people have
which is they do tend to think
worst-case scenario.
Like, there is a kind of,
"What if this goes wrong?
What if this goes sideways?"
thinking
that can be hard to come t
if you're a generally happy,
optimistic person.
But I think it's been very
helpful for thinking about this.
-You were one
of the first people
to talk how serious
this could get.
And I feel as though journalists
like yourself
had to toe the line
between both early reporting
and balancing it with the idea
of being alarmist.
Did you feel at any point that
you were screaming into the void
in the early days of this?
-I did. I mean, I definitely
did, particularly --
The period where it really fel
like screaming into the void
was when it was clear we had
a very sizable, rapidly
accelerating outbreak
in those first two weeks
of March,
before the real steps happened
Once we documented
community transmission --
In February, I think, you know
I had that feeling, too,
I don't want to freak people
out. And I would say,
"Yes," you know, "the flu
kills a lot of people.
And the odds of you being hi
by this remain relatively low,
which was true at the time
But, like,
if you look at New York now,
like New York City,
that wouldn't prove to be true
in the long run.
So, yes. To me,
the real breaking points
are when Dr. Messonnier
at the CDC in late Februar
does that telephone briefing
where she says
people should start talkin
about their schools,
about, like, teleschooling
And people were like, "What?
Teleschool?
What are you talking about
We're not gonna
shut down schools."
Then it was like
three weeks later,
we've shut down every school
And when she said that,
that to me was a trigger
of, like, "Oh. We're going
where Italy has gone.
We're going where
Wuhan has gone.
Like, we're all on the same --
We're all sailing
to the same destination."